Francine as I speak as I tell you the
story shares continue to slide they're
now down by thirteen point seven percent
so literally in a matter of minutes
since 1045 what are we now 1053 local
time in a matter of minute it's lost ten
percent of its value which leads me to
the two-day performance because in the
last two days the shares of now fallen
by thirty percent this is incredible 22
billion euro this is higher that the
penalties many think Volkswagen could be
imposed at a worst-case scenario all
right Mike let's also go back to Hans
because hunter you know to put this into
context so 11 million vehicles have been
affected now this doesn't mean that
we'll have 11 million recalls if you
look at the huge numbers so Volkswagen
is basically neck-and-neck with Toyota
they produce 10 million a year this is
basically the production for a whole
entire year a full swaggin being
effective and you know if the problem
started in 2009 we can back that out and
say they've roughly produced in the
range of 55 million vehicles since 2009
so that would represent about twenty
percent of the vehicles out there I want
to say something that might be a little
bit contrary here mark made the
comparison between Volkswagen and BP in
this statement that Volkswagen is
putting out there almost doubling down
on their defense they're saying that the
software did not affect emissions it did
not affect handling either but for
Volkswagen after what they've been
through and you have to imagine that it
in red Wolfsburg they've had a difficult
24 or 48 hours for them to say now as
they're gathering the facts that this
software did not affect emissions it may
be the beginning of us getting
Volkswagens side of the story outside
the story will be litigated will be
challenged the EPA obviously doesn't
very much trust Volkswagen they don't
like though what they've done and we
have Volkswagen publicly saying that
they've screwed up here but the idea
that they're saying there's software and
that's what we're talking about this
this defeat device they are saying their
software didn't affect emissions I'm
having a difficult time squaring that
statement out of company headquarters
with what vendor corn said on Sunday
which is we screwed up and what the
head of North American operations said
late last night in New York saying that
we've made a mistake we've lost trust so
I think there's a lot more we need to
know about just what went on with these
defeat devices and whether or not
Volkswagen thought that they were
somehow within if not the spirit of the
law the color of the law